hey cheyenne hey booboo hi
hey how you guys doing good
good okay so
just so that i know for sure so when it
comes to the descendants films this is
the animated film that accompanies that
correct awesome so boo boo for you being
a part of the original films what was it
like doing an animated version
um you know
it was really interesting you know when
you're in the booth you're not wearing
the outfit you're not on set you're not
speaking to other people especially
during this for this time around because
it's covered
uh we were just by ourselves and there's
a giant screen in front of us with all
these different faces from around the
world of like the the director the
writer the music people that all the
people and uh
yeah you gotta just you gotta use your
imagination a lot and it's there's a
certain sense of freedom in that because
you get to give them a wide range of
options and
but yeah definitely
is different
yeah
yeah
now did you stay in contact with the
cast while you're doing this because
essentially you're doing this voice on
your own but were you able to keep in
contact with everyone
um there definitely was a uh
because of we felt like you know the
last to send us through was kind of
the wrap-up of the series there
definitely was
uh talk and like oh
you know oh they just we want to do this
with the with descendants and they're
going to want to do a special after do
you guys want to do that between
us all and so there was
talk of that between the cast
but um aside from that
in the mix of you know performing it
there were no real communication because
we all did it separately
yeah
cheyenne how much fun was it for you
coming on as hades
so fun i mean i
i had come from american horror story
and all of this really heady dark stuff
so when this audition came
um i just thought lord of the underworld
and he has the blue mohawk
yes please
um
also i was looking for something that my
kids could see and um and kenny ortega
has just this incredible
track record of making these emotional
and high energy and really polished uh
products so um i loved it i loved i
loved being a part of it i loved seeing
coming on set and seeing boo boo and cam
and sophia and dove and the the world
that they've created in the family and
then being able to come on and be
campy and bigger than life and and and
the disrupter so
it's been actually just to get real for
a second it's actually it's been a huge
gift in my life because now
yeah now i you know 10 year olds come up
to me and say hades and i've never had
that it's always been you know
fans from different things so this is
this is uh
it's a whole whole new whole new world
and it opened me up and yeah it's been
great i love that so were your kids fans
of descendants before you joined well
they're little they're only four and a
half so they were yeah they were two
when i shot the sentence three so they
kind of knew what was going on but now
they're old enough to watch it and they
and they love hades and they love you
know but they get a little confused when
little kids come up to me i bet they're
like wait a minute
but then now they know yeah it's fun oh
that's amazing okay then boo boo for
fans of the descendants films what are
you excited for them to see when it
comes to the royal wedding
um sorry my my audio is going a little
crazy right now so i don't know if you
can hear it on your end but
people um
just what i'm excited for people to see
is just the continuation of the growth
of the characters where they're all at
in their lives
i'm very very excited for them to hear
the new song feeling the love
it's a beautiful song that total just
totally wrap it gives the energy of all
the descendants films in one song
and that represents uh what we've built
together as a family um
so i'm yeah very very very excited for
people to hear the song when i first
heard it i got goosebumps and many
emotions surprisingly kim came over me
as it's a beautiful song
yeah um you know i know your other
co-stars have spoken openly about how
difficult it was even doing another
descendants project without cameron um
how did you feel about that
uh a lot of mixed emotions um that was
when i first heard that they wanted to
do
something else with descendants i was
very reluctant i
didn't honestly didn't wasn't really
like up on the idea
uh but i was like
i'll just read it and see
where they're thinking of taking things
and after reading the script i was
really taken back and i was this is we
should tell the story and we should give
this
to the people uh to the fans uh to the
everyone who supported us for so for so
long
um
we
the way they honor cameron is beautiful
yeah and uh
yeah i i think they really really
touched on it perfectly and it's
it's very nice and yeah and
job well done from their part and
that really sold it for me i was like
okay this is this is meant to be
i love hearing that uh cheyenne are you
currently filming something in vancouver
right now
i was i just rapped i'm doing uh
rachel dratch and anna gasteyer uh wrote
a holiday film you know because there's
so many
hallmark and and so they it's a it's a
send up of holiday films and it's called
a cluster funk christmas
and um
yeah that's really funny
i'm obsessed with holiday films you have
no idea is there anything you can tease
us we're all you're gonna be into this
then i can't tease anything yet but i do
i can say i play uh frank clusterfunk
and my my two aunts are on a gaster and
rachel dratch and we all we all run and
in
and it's it's it's every it's like
oh funny
no i mean it's like it's like what
airplane did for
that kind of genre i think rachel dratch
and anna gasteyer have written this and
i just think this is the first of many
things they're writing together it's the
first feature they've written together
and it's it's just we could not even
keep straight faces it's
ridiculous oh my god the best way i'm so
excited like i cannot tell you my
obsession with holiday films so that's
awesome this is going to be your jam for
sure
and just wrapping things up you know boo
boo it's so amazing looking at all the
films that you've been in huge
franchises of course with twilight i
feel like everybody in the world knows
all four films now on uh netflix um for
you what was it like being a part of
twilight at like the height of its
popularity
good question
yeah i mean honestly when i look back at
twilight those are we spent so much time
on the road promoting them and doing
events and
gosh
i don't even know if i'll ever
experience something like that again
um
it's one thing to have a film that's
really
loved and every but twilight is just
kind of a beast of its own
it's really the way people reacted to it
and um
gosh some of the events we would go to
it was just insane and so much
there was just so much energy in the air
uh i guess that's the way that's the
best way to put it just the energy in
the air was just so
powerful and electric and anytime we did
anything for twilight it was just like
this
surge of energy and
you know i can't even explain it's hard
to explain
um
but yeah the energy was just electric
and just very intense
um
and i'm so happy that you know like my
little sister um when i was doing
twilight
she was too young to really understand
what it was
um
she's more she loves descendants and got
to be more part of that
um
but now she's she's 15 and she's re
she's discovering twilight
yeah which is crazy because they put it
on netflix and she's reading the book
she takes her with her everywhere and
she loves twilight and she's watching
the movies all the time
and so uh
yeah i don't know just so much energy so
much energy everywhere
i can only imagine well if netflix and
all the popularity has said anything
twilight's not going anywhere
it's still so popular
amazing guys congratulations on this
film somebody's getting to talk about
you